[Music]
so
hello thank you so much for clicking on
this video i really appreciate it
spring is in the air here in southern
spain that's all i can say
we've had some seriously dull and wet
days
but every time there is a beautiful
sunny day it is
warmer than one would expect for this
time of year
but i love it i love it and along with
the warmth
come the pests the baby pests
or the adults that in the autumn have
laid all their eggs
on my orchids and then depending on what
kind of orchid it is
they either hatch and thrive and destroy
my orchids
or they just go on their merry way and
find something else to use as a buffet
and what you see here is my dendrobium
nephrits alex pauli
and the damage of a pest that i have
here in my area
which is a moth larvae which is my newt
and the eggs go on to new growths
old growths it is not fussy
where it puts its eggs and you can
hardly see
the damage happening because that little
let me say bugger is so tiny
that its eggs and its larvae are a
fraction of that and for me
at least not visible to the naked eye
this is a dead one
thank goodness but this is a culprit
that is doing damage and it is always
going
for my dendrobium types and i am quite
frankly
fed up i have tried several insecticides
also
on a soap basis and yeah check this out
that is just
that's that you know i'm i'm lucky that
i
i can manage to save this one
but all my den files went downhill
because every time they tried to produce
a new growth
there was already eggs or something
lodged in those new growths and they
didn't develop
anywhere beyond what they should have
done so in the bin with the denfalls
so it has attacked other dendrobiums
and it looks like it could be spider
mite damage but it's not
it really isn't i never wipe off and
have anything orange on me it's
it's this flipping moth larvae so the
insecticidal soap i can wipe the leaves
down
i have made a mistake to sometimes wipe
them down during the day because
that is when i have time and at night
you never know if it's going to be
too cold at this time of year to have
wet leaves
but during the day was a big mistake
because it
affects the stomata and the stomata on
the dendrobiums are open
during the day so i am going to give
credit to
a channel called orgyplanet spanish
channel i believe he's
adrian is in ecuador and he recently put
up a video
saying he uses or shows that the use of
garlic for pests on the orchids
and i was like okay i looked up the
components and things and properties of
garlic
to see what that was all about and read
up about
the allium sativan leaf lecithin which
is a
protein highly anti-nutritional and
toxic to some insects
aphids snails and then it talked about
larvae and the mealy beetle the meli
beetle has
larvae and when those are placed by the
adults
on the plant it will hatch at such a
time when the temperatures start to
become a little bit more conducive to
its survival
and start to have a sucking effect on
the membrane and the tissue of the
leaves
and again it doesn't distinguish all the
new growths
when i hear larvae i think of my moth
larvae
and i am going to give this a go and i
want to talk through
my preparation process to get this up
and running and ready for use
the essential oils in the garlic
is not apparently just nice for gambas
peel peel
or pasta alioli or anything like that
it is good for pests and i'm gonna go
for it
that includes spider mites and i think i
already mentioned
aphids i'm not sure spider mites aphids
anything to do with a larvae and snails
so let us prepare some concoctions
because based on my research recently
i've also noticed that it is good for as
a fungicide
with a different preparation but we'll
give it a go
so i'm going to consider that the asl
which is the alien sativum leaflet
citing
found in garlic as part of a protein and
the corresponding essential oils
i'm going to hedge my bets now and
try and do this and see if it works
because i need to make sure that my
dendrobiums
and some of my epiderm crosses
are showing similar signs that they are
protected
now i have here five
cloves of garlic and yes i'm just
putting all the
skin and everything on the floor because
hey
if it repels insects and repels
larvae and all that from feeding
and sucking out the
um the juices of the growths
the leaves the tissue this is going
on the floor so maybe i can start the
process in the garden at some point
but to my understanding
there is no harm to be doing this on the
orchids
during the day it is natural
and it is also used in many many
pesticides the only time
that i have heard about this was on
adrienne's channel so for
the pesticide that i'm preparing here
i'm just going to chop up small pieces
of garlic
but enough that you get a good
concentration
i wouldn't puree it because it's going
to go into a
pump spray so no puree just the pieces
you want the essential oils to come out
and leech into the solution
so i'm just making these pieces small
enough so that i can fill them
into my little pump spray
which is a beautiful beautiful container
this can be clear or whatever i just
don't go and buy something new my
daughter helped me find something to
recycle
this was a little bit of a body spray
from douglas very delicious but i
cleaned it out and it is now
my pump spray because i needed a measure
of a hundred milliliters
so the color doesn't matter if you don't
like
this color you can go with clear it
doesn't have to be opaque that's got
nothing to do
with how the solution is going to react
over time
100 milliliters though is the measure
and i have on the bottom here
already 30 percent of the little
container
filled with just plain ro water it
doesn't have to be ro water if you have
soft water in the home
please use that that's fine but i have
water in here because i only have 96
percent of pure alcohol so i am just
bringing it down to 70
so isopropyl alcohol 70
that is what you want
and that is why i put water in first in
order to to dilute
my alcohol
let's get that on there so we avoid
evaporation
this should be my pesticide in 24 hours
leave it refrigerated because you don't
want
the garlic to degrade become moldy or
fungus so
it is organic and you want to leave this
for at least three to six hours 24 hours
is the best though and then you have
yourself a wonderful garlic solution
which next day
you spray onto the orchid
right now it's obviously not going to
work but for the point of demonstration
that is what you do 70 isopropyl alcohol
enough garlic on the bottom i used five
small cloves if you have one big one
that is fine as well i don't believe
that any kind of concentration is of any
harm whatsoever but you want the
components
at least to give them plenty of time to
dissolve
and ooze into the alcohol and become
your solution so this is going to go
into the fridge
and tomorrow because it's going to be a
sunny day i'm going for it
got to try this i don't want to have
any new growths that are already
starting right here
become targets when i see something
black like that
i get suspicious
so that's coming off and i believe i
already started
it has already started because look
there we go that's already one point of
destruction right there
so it is already happening this is high
noon
and i am not going to have it if i if
this doesn't work i will definitely
update you but if it does work
you will also find out if it doesn't
work i'm going back to my insecticidal
soap and i'll be wiping at night
however another thing i found out
was the fact that this garlic the
essential oils are great as a fungicide
and i am going to make my solution for
that
today as well here i have
all the measurements on the jug just to
make life easier so it's one pint
or 16 ounces make sure i'm in
or two cups
or in my case half a liter
as you can see in the back there so
that's the measurement and in here i
have ro
water again because my tap water is
really bad quality and whatever i spray
on my orchids i do not want that
to affect the leaves here i have
ground garlic and that is
a quarter of a cup american but it is
actually half full which is
an eighth of a cup of ground garlic
i used five large cloves
i mean this size
okay this is a little bit smaller but
that's why i took the measurement out
but
five large garlic cloves which for me
came
out to an eighth of a cup
and that is going to go into the water
and this has to marinade and sit
and become one
for a day as well it's best the longer
is
you can do this and leave it the better
and then you strain out the garlic
and then you have yourself a fungicide
so now i'm really hungry the smell of
garlic always makes me hungry
[Laughter]
but if this works then i am
absolutely going to be over the moon
because i have myself
an insecticide that i can use during the
day on the underside of the leaves
without destroying the growth
at least three hours best 24 hours
store in the fridge and the fungicide
if you're gonna go with a high quantity
store in the fridge once you've strained
it
let it seep for about 24 hours and then
strain out the garlic chunks if you're
doing a small quantity like this
it's going to be used up at this at the
moment that it's ready to be used
for me in my case i'm going to probably
double the next dose
so i have enough to go around this
is my attempt to get ahead of the game
with regards to
the moth larvae and i am hoping
to come out on top this year quite
frankly i am tired of eventually seeing
these marks
let's hope we're successful because if
that is the case eventually i'll buy in
some more
dendrobium phalaenopsis because i do
like them
i just can't seem to keep them alive
because of this pest
issue i have which attacks
mainly my dendrobiums so i appreciate
you watching i hope that you
found this helpful again the credit goes
to orkyplanet and his name is
adrian i will leave a link to that video
down below
but i wanted to bring this to
everybody's attention because from here
on in
at least for the next month i will be
using this solution and if anybody asks
i can reference
this video if you've ever used garlic
as a pest control i would be super
interested to know if it had any results
or if it's just a
old wives tale and it doesn't actually
work
let me know in the comments below thank
you so very very much for watching i
really appreciate it have yourselves a
wonderful wonderful day take care
[Music]
bye
you